- [Johnny] If a person robs you on land,
they're a thief.
But if they rob you at sea,
they're a pirate.
Let's say it's 2007
and you're the captain of a cargo ship
traveling off the coast
of the Horn of Africa.
You're transporting wheat
from Kenya to Saudi Arabia.
When you look out at the ocean
and you see these guys.
They come at you quickly,
just a small speedboat of them,
and soon they're right up
against the side of your ship.
They're about to throw
a ladder to climb up.
You run into the ship's
citadel, or safe room,
and you call the Coast Guard.
Or maybe you try to spray
them with this water hose
to scare them away.
But it's too late.
They've now climbed on board.
They're rounding up the crew.
They're gonna hold you hostage
and demand a ransom of millions of dollars
for anyone who will pay.
The shipping company, your
home government, your family,
doesn't matter.
And if you don't give them the money,
you'll be held in captivity,
starving, maybe even tortured
for days, weeks, months, even years.
- If there's no answer
to payment of the ransom
within three days,
then the kidnappers here
will sell me to Al-Shabaab.
- [Johnny] This happened
hundreds of times.
This is what a typical hijacking
in this region looked like
in the early 2000's,
where by the end of the decade,
hundreds of piracy incidents
were reported every year
and they were still just getting started.
So let me show you how the Horn of Africa
became the epicenter of modern-day piracy
and how what started as Somali fishermen
defending their waters
turned into an organized criminal network.
This is the rise and
fall of Somali pirates.
- [Reporter] Off the Somali coast
where those pirates attacked that vessel.
(pirate screaming)
(aggressive electronic music)
- [Commentator] You're dealing
with irrational people.
- [Commentator] If your
back is against the wall,
I don't know what they are able to do.
- Okay, little sidebar really quick.
Yes, I'm wearing my orange jacket inside
because it's kind of cold in the studio.
Anyway.
One of my least favorite parts
about living in the internet age
is how tracked I am and
how tracked we all are.
I spend a lot of time on the internet,
and when I do that,
all of my data, all of
my browsing behavior,
my purchase history, my address,
my Social Security number,
my location history
is scraped by some shadowy company
and put onto a list
and then bought and
sold in an open market.
This is why my inbox is chaos,
why my phone is always
blowing up with robocalls,
why I'm constantly being marketed to
and sent stuff to my
house that I don't want.
It's a nightmare and it's
getting worse every year.
People's data is being
more and more exploited,
not just by marketers,
but by recruiting companies
and financial companies
and risk management companies
and people search sites
so that people can search you.
It's like not cool.
Luckily, we all have rights
to get ourselves off of these lists.
The problem is no one's
gonna spend the time
going through the bureaucracy
to actually get yourself off
these hundreds of lists
that you are probably on.
And that is where Incogni comes in.
Incogni is the sponsor of today's video,
as you probably have gathered,
and I'm very grateful to
them for sponsoring the video
and supporting our journalism.
But also I'm grateful that they exist.
Because I didn't know about them
until they came to sponsor a video,
and now I'm a super fan.
You sign up for Incogni and
you give them permission
to go out on your behalf
to take you off all of these lists.
When I signed up for it,
they were able to scan and see
that I was on dozens of
lists, over a hundred lists,
and they were able to show
me what lists I was on.
It's all on this nice-looking dashboard.
And then the best part
is you get to sit back and watch Incogni
do all the work for you,
go and fight to get you
off all of these lists.
Sometimes that's as easy
as just a little request
that they do and they
get you off the list.
Sometimes they get
pushback from the company,
and they will do that fight for you
until you are off that list.
And you just get to sit
back and watch it happen.
I'm really glad that they invented this
because it has been getting out of hand.
Like we love the internet, it's great,
but like this data exploitation thing
is getting out of hand.
And I swear someday we're
gonna look back on all this
and be like, "That was the Wild West."
For now, Incogni is a
great tool to protect you
and protect your privacy.
So there's a link in my description.
It's incogni.com/johnnyharris.
Click the link.
You help support the channel,
but you also get 60%
off their annual plan.
Why do you need an annual plan?
Because when they take you off a list,
inevitably if you continue
to use the internet,
you'll end up back on that list.
Incogni constantly
monitors month after month
to make sure that you
stay off of these lists.
Soon, your inbox will
not look like pure chaos.
Your phone will quiet down.
Mine sure has.
And you can rest easy
knowing that your data isn't
just out there searchable
by any corporation or person who wants it.
So the link is in the description.
Thank you, Incogni, for
sponsoring the video.
Let's dive into this big topic of pirates.
Pirates aren't one thing.
They've always existed.
As long as there's been
international trade on the ocean,
there have been pirates,
sailors who utilize the
expanse of the open ocean
to rob and steal and run
sophisticated businesses.
If you haven't seen CGP
Grey's deep dive on pirates,
go watch it.
It's a two-parter.
Pirates are everything from Norse sailors
who raided other ships on the high seas
to the famous pirates of the Caribbean,
like Britain's Blackbeard,
who stole a French slave ship
and souped it up into the
ultimate pirate vessel.
Pirates were poor men
who were looking for
money and social mobility.
Some of them were looking
for fame and glory and power
in a time where seafaring men
had little status or
opportunity in society.
We've romanticized them,
we've caricatured them,
and we idealize them as
legends and myths of the past.
But piracy never fully went away.
It still very much exists today.
Here's a map of all the piracy incidents
over the past 40 years,
at least the reported ones.
From Indonesian pirates
hijacking cargo ships
in the Strait of Malacca
to Bangladeshi pirates
holding fishermen hostage
in exchange for ransoms,
all the way to West Africa,
where Nigerian pirates
steal oil off huge tankers
and sell it on the black market.
But most of the dots on
this map are right here,
the gateway to the Suez Canal,
one of the busiest
highways of global trade,
off the coast of a country
where piracy uniquely could thrive.
The government of Somalia
collapsed in the early '90's,
the country fractured,
and instead of a central government,
local clans started to control
patches of the country.
There was no real government
to regulate this
3,000-kilometer coastline,
the longest coastline in Africa.
As a result, huge fishing boats,
mostly from Iran and Yemen,
took advantage of this free-for-all,
swooping in to these unregulated
Somali waters to fish.
These foreign fishers would steal
hundreds of millions of
dollars of seafood every year
with nets that tear up the sea floor,
destroying the ecosystem
and depleting the fish
stock in the process.
This illegal fishing by foreign vessels
started to outsize the catch of locals
whose water this was.
Local Somali fishermen
with their tiny boats
couldn't compete,
and soon this illegal foreign fishing
eclipsed the catch of local Somalis.
Around the same time,
companies from Switzerland
and Somali's former colonizer Italy
were illegally paying corrupt factions
of the Somali government
to take their toxic waste,
some of it even being radioactive.
Tons of this waste ended up
in both Somalia's land and water,
which would go on to
have significant effects
on the health of local communities.
So it's the 1990s,
and between the illegal
overfishing and the waste dumping,
Somali people's main livelihood
is being pillaged by foreigners.
And they don't really have a
government to help them out,
to protect them.
So some Somalis decided to fight back.
- An American cargo ship
taken over by pirates.
- Somali fishermen got together,
and they formed an ocean militia.
Some would call themselves
the Coast Guard,
and they would use these tiny boats
to chase down foreign fishing vessels
and demand that they pay a fine.
Some experts have called
this subsistence piracy
because it was piracy,
but it was also kind of fishermen
defending their livelihood
from predatory foreigners.
And at first it was rare.
I mean, if you look at the data,
you just see a handful of
successful incidents every year.
Oh, and they were pretty basic too.
Like in one of these early
incidents of Somali piracy
back in like 1994,
you've got this wooden
boat full of 26 Somali men
claiming to be the Somali Coast Guard,
and they go up to a shipping vessel
and they get on board.
They like hijack it for five days,
but realize they can't really do anything
so they just steal as much as
they can from the cargo ship
and just go on their way.
Yes, this was piracy,
but it was super basic
and kind of harmless.
It was a bunch of locals
filling in on the power vacuum
left by their non-existent government.
And this is how it was for a long time.
Loosely organized gangs
of armed Somali men
climbing aboard cargo
ships or fishing vessels,
intimidating the crews to collect fines
or sometimes asking for
informal license fees
for fishing in their waters
even though they didn't have any authority
to give out licenses.
They did it to get money,
to basically be like,
"If you're gonna fish in our waters,
"you need to pay us."
And the rest of the world
didn't really know about this.
It like wasn't big enough
news for anyone to care.
But that would soon change.
- Across the region,
80,000 people are dead.
At least 22,000 of them were
killed here in Sri Lanka.
- So there's kind of a turning point.
Christmas 2004.
This tsunami was devastating,
mostly in Southeast Asia,
but it also hit Somalia's
really delicate coast,
destroying homes and boats
and crippling an already
delicate economy and food supply.
- [Reporter] The tsunami took the lives
of some 150 people in Somalia
and poisoned the precious
little water supply
that people had here.
- And it also washed up
some of that toxic waste
that had been dumped off their shores.
This led to a UN investigation,
which concluded that the waste
was likely causing severe damage
to the health of local people.
And at this point,
Somalia still isn't one country.
There's some parts of the country
that are peaceful and safe
and under government control,
but most of Somalia is still a patchwork
of competing clans and warlords,
a hotbed for terrorism and
organized crime networks
that controlled different
parts of the country.
(soldier chanting)
And piracy, this thing that started off
as an informal Coast Guard,
was maturing in sophisticated ways.
(ethereal electronic music)
By 2005, you start to see
pirates using motherships,
larger ships that allow them
to go way further off their coast,
and then to use speedboats to attack
like they did to this cargo ship.
This was a huge level-up
for Somali pirates.
These motherships started
to be equipped with radar,
which allowed the pirates
to have new ways of detecting their prey.
You start to see them have
GPS systems or satellite
phones to communicate.
Pirates start looking at
shipping industry blogs and databases
to locate and track shipping vessels.
This was turning from
basic subsistence piracy
to something more sophisticated.
Pirates started to realize
just how much money and value
was flowing through this corridor
headed towards the Suez Canal,
like one of the busiest
highways of international trade
in the world.
And with these new and improved tactics
came more profitable business models
that would change everything for pirates.
- [Reporter] Police in
Finland say the owner
of the missing freighter Arctic Sea
has received a demand for a ransom.
- It was the early 2000's,
and it was the beginning
of the era of ransoms.
- You were kidnapped by Somali pirates
and you were held hostage
for more than two years.
- [Johnny] Hey, Michael,
it's Johnny Harris.
- [Michael] Hi, Johnny,
good to hear from you.
- So we had a really
interesting conversation
with this American journalist
named Michael Scott Moore.
He was kidnapped by Somali pirates
and held for almost three years
before being released for
a $1.6 million ransom.
- [Michael] And people say,
"Oh, but they're just
frustrated fishermen."
They're not.
They were in the '90's,
but it was a much bigger deal
than just fishermen turning to piracy.
- Ransoms changed everything.
Pirates were realizing how easy it was
to hold a ship hostage
and to demand a multimillion dollar ransom
to extract a huge profit,
which attracted the attention of warlords,
who saw a business opportunity.
Warlords now wanted to fund hijackings
like this one
where pirates were hijacking
a Ukrainian coal ship
that was traveling from
South Africa to Turkey.
They could hold it hostage and release it
only in exchange for $700,000,
which is what they got.
Or another instance where
pirates riding on speedboats
captured this Japanese ship
and its 20-person crew,
holding them hostage
until somebody coughed up $2 million.
There was investment in
these pirate operations
because there was a return to be had.
And by 2007, around 30% of
the world's pirate attacks
occurred within this circle.
But wait, let's keep this in perspective.
This actually wasn't particularly high.
If you look at a graph
of all of the other regions of the world,
you'll see that this wasn't
by any means an outlier.
But watch what happens the next year.
This line going up
represents the expansion of
the piracy industry in Somalia.
There was way too much
money to be made here,
and warlords were
getting better and better
at investing in and
running pirate businesses.
By 2009, this body of water off of Somalia
was home to nearly half of
all piracy incidents on Earth.
And look at this graph of
the average ransoms paid.
In 2008, the average ransom
was a million dollars.
A total of $30 million
was paid out that year.
And you gotta keep this in perspective,
these were huge sums of money for anyone,
but especially poor
fishermen turned pirates
in a country with a GDP per
person of $517 per year.
But even still,
this was just the beginning.
- If you'd simply refuse to pay,
I mean, the pirates
have a lot of hostages.
The consequences of those
being shot, for instance,
would be unimaginable.
- All of this influx of ransom cash
kicked off a pirate economy cycle
where pirates would attack a ship,
hold the crew hostage,
and get paid a high ransom.
They would bring this back
to the clan leader warlord
who funded them,
which would make that person rich
and allow them to invest in bigger boats
and more guns and
recruiting more young men
and appeasing the local
coastal communities
who would support them,
which they would use to hijack more ships
in more sophisticated ways.
And it repeated and repeated,
getting more and more sophisticated
and dangerous each time.
- [Michael] So a businessman
who gets to be so rich
that he needs to protect his
business interests with gunmen,
that's a warlord.
And a pirate boss is nothing else.
He's a businessman who invests in piracy.
- The pirate businesses
had lawyers and cooks
and bank-note tellers
with machines that could detect fake bills
so that they could know
if their ransom cash
was real or not.
There was this great reporting
at the time in 2009 by Reuters.
One of their journalists
went to a pirate town
that had been a sleepy fishing village
but had turned into a booming pirate hub,
or in their words, pirate lair.
What Reuters found was that
this economy was so booming
that they had created a stock exchange
where any local in the town
could invest what they had
into a piracy business.
There were dozens of
these piracy businesses,
and you can invest in the one
that you think is gonna
go get a successful ransom
by hijacking an international
shipping vessel.
And people made a lot of money.
One local said they made
$75,000 in just a couple months
because they had made a good
bet on the right pirates.
- [Michael] Pirate bosses
were not just top pirates,
they were investors who had
a portfolio of businesses.
- These pirate businesses
would in turn support these communities,
help fund the schools and the hospitals
in order to curry favor with the locals
to make sure that they would support them
running their businesses.
But the people who were
really getting rich here
were mostly the clan leaders, the warlords
who were building massive
villas and buying luxury cars
and throwing lavish, drug-laden parties.
This was no longer the DIY Coast Guard.
This was now lucrative organized crime.
And yet some of these pirate groups
still tried to make a moral case
as to why they were
justified in doing this,
saying that this wasn't piracy,
this was retaliation
for all of the exploitation
of Somali waters
by foreign countries.
You see this in a 2008
hijacking of a Ukrainian vessel,
when these pirates demand $8 million,
claiming that they would use the money
to clean up the toxic waste
that European companies
had dumped in their waters.
Yes, European companies have
dumped toxic waste in Somalia.
Were these pirates actually
going to use the $8 million
to clean that up?
Probably not.
At least that's what we
found in our reporting.
A lot of the moralistic,
like Robin Hood narrative
became really thin once
warlords got involved
and once they demanded a
return for their investment.
And you just start to see how
thin this moral argument is
when pirates start boarding ships
and just shooting crew at random
to show how serious they were
and to increase the likelihood
of getting a high ransom payout.
- Unfortunately, there is
one seaman from mainland
who was killed by by the Somali pirates.
- [Johnny] Or when they
started hijacking UN ships
that were full of food and medical aid
meant for Somali people.
- The ship apparently was
bound for Mombasa, Kenya,
and the shipment included
vegetable oil, corn, soy blend,
and other basic food commodities
bound for people in countries
including Somalia, Uganda, and Kenya.
- This was about money and power,
and it was able to thrive
because of a country that
didn't have a government
that actually controlled the country.
By 2011, there were 237
piracy incidents here.
Over 1,200 hostages were taken that year.
35 of them died while in captivity.
This was becoming more and more deadly
and more and more lucrative.
Let's go back to that graph
of the average ransoms that were paid.
You can see it grow up
to around $5 million
for the average ransom.
The total number of ransoms paid in 2011?
$150 million.
It was getting out of hand,
but it would take a few key events
for the world to really take notice.
- [Captain] Ladies and gentlemen,
ladies and gentlemen,
all ships stay inside,
stay inside, stay inside.
We are trying to run away from them.
Now, stay inside everybody.
This is a real alarm.
Please stay inside.
- There's this funny thing
in international news
where in order for the world
to take notice of something,
it sort of has to affect like Westerners.
And that's no different with pirates.
There was this one incident
in the fall of 2005
where a group of pirates showed
up to a luxury cruise ship.
It was full of Western tourists.
- They hit us with rocket grenades, RPGs.
There was a woman in her cabin,
and she was fortunately in her bathroom,
but a rocket grenade went right through
and blew the whole cabin up.
- The cruise ship escaped,
but it still led to global news coverage.
Another incident was in 2008
when a Ukrainian ship was
hijacked by these pirates.
Little did these pirates know
they had just stumbled upon a shipment
of tanks and grenades and
ammunition bound for Sudan.
They were demanding $35
million to give it back,
holding the crew and the ship hostage.
The U.S. and Russia both freaked out here,
and they sent in their navys
to like monitor the situation
to make sure the pirates
weren't gonna take the
weapons off the boat.
In the end,
the pirates agreed to
a $3.2 million payout,
and the secret weapons
shipment continued onward.
It was a big scare,
and it was another step
in waking the world up
to how big of a deal this was becoming.
But the biggest event
happened a few months later.
A U.S. container ship was
traveling from Oman to Kenya
when four pirates boarded
and hijacked the ship,
holding the crew hostage
and demanding $2 million.
The U.S. government has a firm policy
that it doesn't negotiate with hostages,
but what they do do is
send in their military.
So after four days,
the Navy Seals arrived with snipers.
They shot three of the four
pirates and rescued the crew.
It was an incident that was later depicted
in this Tom Hanks movie.
These were dramatic events,
a hostage situation with
snipers and Navy Seals,
and it spread into the
international news cycle
in a way that Somali
piracy just hadn't before.
- [Reporter] Captain
Phillips was taken hostage
for almost five days
and then rescued by the U.S. Navy.
- It was clear that this had become
too lucrative of an economy.
There was too much incentive for warlords
to get in on all of this
money for it to stop.
The only way to slow this down
was a serious intervention.
As we were reporting this story,
I kept asking like,
"Why is this such a
difficult problem to solve?"
And we asked all of the
experts we interviewed,
and we have a pretty good idea now
why this is way more
complicated than expected.
First off, guns.
You can't really carry guns
on international shipping vessels,
partly because there's
international gun laws
that are complicated,
partly because shipping companies
don't want guns on boats
because it can be a weird liability thing.
You can't just have like a
gun in a safe box somewhere.
Second, it's hard to send in the navys
to patrol these waters
because pirates often
don't look like pirates
until it's too late,
at which point they're prone
to use their victims as human shields
against any threatening navy.
So unless you've got like the
best snipers in the world,
like the Navy Seals,
it's actually really hard to use
just like military force
against these pirates.
And lastly, you have to remember
what we're talking about.
We're talking about the open ocean,
huge swaths of water.
It's really challenging
to monitor and control
this in an effective way.
It's one reason why piracy
has always thrived on the open sea.
But even despite all these challenges,
governments and businesses
put their heads together
and they figured something out.
The first one's kind of boring.
It's this report
that this international
shipping organization put out
that basically teaches ships
and captains and companies
how to protect themselves.
They recommend them using
this high-pressure hose
that allows 'em to just like
spray water at the pirates.
They started recommending
putting barbed wire and
razor wire around your ship.
Kind of gnarly.
Put locks on your doors,
increase your surveillance.
Like this is pretty basic stuff.
Create a safe room or a citadel
where you can like lock
yourself in if you get hijacked.
But one of the big things they did
was create this
internationally-recognized corridor
where ships could all travel
together like in a caravan,
sometimes escorted by a navy ship
from one of these countries,
helping them navigate this really busy
but very vulnerable part
of the international shipping highway.
And another huge step was,
in spite of all the complicated gun laws,
vessels were now allowed
to employ armed guards
to stand watch as they
navigate these waters.
So now you've got like security guards
with guns on the ship
who have nothing else to do
but like protect the boat.
And guess what?
All of these strategies totally worked.
I mean, look at this graph.
After its all-time high in 2011,
hijacking incidents plummeted
because of these interventions.
But this leaves us
with kind of a complicated
resolution here.
These communities were left
behind by their government.
They don't have the
infrastructure of a society
where people can thrive and work.
That's for a lot of reasons,
but it's in part because of the pillaging
and the exploitation from outsiders.
And so while these warlords
who committed horrific crimes to get rich
deserve no moral justification,
it is morally complicated
when you look at people who
are just trying to live,
whose waters have been
poisoned by toxic waste,
whose country has been pillaged,
and who turned to piracy as a last resort.
But I'm not gonna go into
the ethical dilemma here.
I think you all can fight that out
in the comments if you want.
I'd love to see what you have to say.
The fact is piracy was
solved in the Horn of Africa
because of these interventions,
at least for the most part.
But just as Somali piracy was declining,
incidents of piracy started popping up
on the other side of the continent.
The Gulf of Guinea took Somalia's title
as the piracy hotspot of the world.
These attacks happen
for different reasons,
and they look quite different.
They're usually Nigerian pirates
boarding oil tankers
to steal the oil that they feel like
was stolen from their land.
The international community
is now turning its focus here,
and this is a more
complicated thing to solve
for a lot more reasons.
The fact is piracy won't go away
as long as the ingredients that
have always fueled it exist.
Frustrated young men with
no chance of finding work
in an economy,
incentivized and organized by clan leaders
looking to get rich on the high seas,
operating in a gray area
where the government and the society
that should support them and employ them
doesn't exist or is too weak to help,
leaving them to fend for themselves
and to turn to more and more
sophisticated forms of crime
in the process.
(plaintive electronic music)
Hey, everyone, look at this map behind me.
I don't know if you caught
it during the video,
but this is a map mostly of East Asia,
but you get this Somali
Peninsula and the Gulf of Aden.
And basically everything
we've talked about,
it's all right here.
It's really a beautiful map.
And when you look at it,
you can see just how
important this Suez Canal is
to global shipping.
Anyway.
I've wanted to look into
Somali pirates forever.
I always saw the news over the years
and never really understood
the story, the background.
And we reported on this,
and we talked to a lot of experts,
and there's actually a
lot of politics in this.
There's a lot of people
who argue for like a vindication
morally of Somali pirates,
saying that they're just retaliating
against a world who's exploited them.
And like there's a strong argument there.
But I don't know.
Again, I'm really curious to hear
what people have to say about it.
Yeah, we are interested in
making deeper and deeper videos.
A video like this takes
much more time and resources
to like really understand,
to get the data.
Like we've got this whole
dataset that we used
to map every incident.
Like that's just like a way bigger thing.
But we want to do more of these.
So I'm curious to hear from you
what stories we should do next.
For those who want to support this effort
of making high-quality, factual videos,
we have a Patreon.
It is called The Newsroom.
That is what we call it.
And it is a place where you
can support with your money
to help make possible what we do here.
You can also buy LUTs and presets,
which are the things that
we use to color our videos
to make our videos look
beautiful like this
and not like this,
which is what it looks
like when we shoot it.
I have a map poster that we sold out of,
but then I'm pretty sure we reprinted it
like a thousand more.
So that should be in stock.
Don't quote me on that.
It could be sold out again by
the time you're watching this.
I have no idea.
Yeah, go watch Search Party,
which is our new channel
that is created by my old Vox colleague
and now my partner, Sam Ellis,
who is building that channel,
but sort of under our
broader company here.
And it's awesome and it
is rigorous and amazing
and really good journalism.
It's called Search Party.
It is here on YouTube.
And I think that's all the
things I need to tell you about
here in my little cozy couch setting.
It's so dim in here.
I feel like I could just
take a nap on this couch.
And I just might.
So thank you all for being here
and for the support and the kind comments
and the appreciation.
And we'll see you soon in the next one.
Bye-bye.
(ethereal electronic music)